haha the Joe Rogan experience I got my
bell rung pretty good I think about a
month ago actually on mats I was
climbing on a guy's back was a good
lesson for me too I was uh slipped over
the top no I I got both of my hands
involved and he rolled and snapped my
head into the mat and I don't have a
chaise planted but I and I didn't again
I don't know [ __ ]
so I'm learning this mistake that I
haven't made since then but yeah I had
my hooks in and was kind of just getting
too involved in that drastic movement
and it was a full whack doing the same
thing in the headache for a few days
afterwards she was get wild when they
they try to get out of things and that
that's a particularly dangerous move
when someone's on your back and you
decide to yeah slam them into the ground
it's kind of a [ __ ] move really well
it would have been okay if I had had at
least one post but like I said I was I
wasn't thinking about that that wasn't
standing did he turn know he was turtled
I don't think I would crawl on
somebody's back if they were standing
it's not very advanced you guys you're
background it you would probably your
digits is probably different than mine
but even taking someone's back standing
is tricky as [ __ ] because they can just
throw themselves backwards and on
concrete oh that's a game over it's a
death sentence that's what I actually
thought about that afterwards because
you will see people who you know I'm
here because I want to learn to protect
myself in the street mm-hmm and if I had
done that on the street and had my head
cracked on concrete and they either been
waking up in the hospital or not at all
you got to kick their legs out in those
situations if you have someone's back
and you're standing you got a you got a
mean the the options that exist that
don't exist in jujitsu one of them is
you kick their [ __ ] legs out if you
have someone's back you know you
actually kick their leg you don't just
just jump on them with the hooks in on
concrete it's just too dangerous before
you get to that position you you want to
yank them and do something trip them do
something to get rid of their base but
someone who's strong that's so dangerous
because someone who's strong can carry
you on their back and then just throw
themselves backwards I mean even
hardwood floor anything or even against
a building or
anything anything you want to get them
to the ground you want to get into the
ground or standing guillotine like you
in your in a front position something
that's another one that's really [ __ ]
dangerous man
see ya guys have gone for takedowns with
guillotines like I said guys shoots in
with it with for a takedown and a guy
grabs a guillotine and pulls back and
then this guy's head is the horse yes
okay a guy on Team Alpha male on your
eye favors team line up getting
paralyzed for life that way yeah in
training on the match yep yeah in
training shoots in for the takedown and
the guy gets him in the guillotine and
they all all their weight together falls
on this guy's head and his neck
compresses and his neck breaks and he
loses his his ability to move for the
rest of his life it's that's a common
one in fact it's not common but it's
happened multiple times that I'm aware
of and you know you gotta imagine on the
street you know someone tries to take
you down on the street and you elevate
and go into a guillotine position and
they fall down and slam their [ __ ]
head first
you gonna crack it open probably - yeah
it's just there's so many I mean one
thing that is a good criticism about
jujitsu is the lack of takedowns and
that is a real factor in any sort of
real world situation the hope is if
you're in a bar something like that
there's a scramble most things wind up
on the ground that's true until you deal
with a skilled opponent and if you deal
with a skilled opponent who has takedown
defense and then you're stuck in the
situation where now you're in a realm
where you're a white belt and this guy's
a black belt look if someone is a
problem a wrestler looking strike it's a
terrible position to be in and we saw
that with a lot of in the early UFC's in
particular a lot of jiu-jitsu blackbelt
just didn't have takedowns and then they
would get involved a wrestler who would
easily stuff their takedown and the
wrestler was a better striker and those
guys got [ __ ] up
you had imagine that'd be a quick belt
it's not good I mean the only thing a
lot of guys did was they would follow
their back and try to pull guard and try
to entice a guy into coming to their
back and then they would kick off there
back like those Hickson use those those
tactics when he fought Funaki right knee
up kick yeah and he actually wanna
[ __ ] up foon Aki's knee by kicking at
his knee hyper extending his knee
friends rugged yeah that's a common
common technique you know guys standing
over you and you're on your back posting
up you hyper extend his knee it's just
like judo is the best in my opinion for
someone who's wearing clothes you know I
think every jiu-jitsu guy would really
greatly benefit from having a good
comprehensive knowledge of judo how deep
would you go
judo is a good thing to learn man just
period first of all those guys are so
freaky chimp strong some of the
freakiest chimp strong guys ever roll
with with judo people cuz judo players
man they're just all everything is to
constantly list they're constantly
grabbing everything is torque and
rotation there's so much explosive
movement carrying a human body it's
right so they're doing explosive
movement like sandbag training with
another 200-pound person all the time or
or larger particular like women like
Ronda Rousey no god damn strong that
woman is she freakishly strong no I bet
because she her whole body was designed
to you know throw bodies around throw a
human body I mean it's like you think of
weightlifting right like when are you
ever weightlifting your whole body well
maybe if you're squatting or maybe if
you're bench pressing if you're
exceptionally strong you're dead lifting
yeah or dead lifting those are like the
compound movements but like curling or
try Supercenter none of those things
overhead press very rarely are you using
your whole body weight that way I don't
think it's advisable to do that with
your whole body weight and your whole
body weight is way more difficult to
control because it's moving and
resisting and it's you know try picking
up a dead body a person who's out cold
it's [ __ ] hard
you got a school a person you're like if
I had to pick up a dude he's 195 pounds
I'm gonna pick him up and he's out cold
[ __ ] that's hard you got to put 80
pounds of gear on yes I would I could
only imagine and guns dangling all over
the place so with a judo player imagine
that but imagine that person also
resists
you know like there's some of the
freakiest strongest people in the world
I just sit down when I start with judo
people oh my ha ha I watch them over in
the corner and I hear just what dish
yeah okay I'm gonna sit down it's a
beautiful thing to learn though it's a
beautiful thing to learn if you can get
someone that'll that'll really work with
you and whose technique oriented not
someone who just wants you to spar all
the time because one of the things that
happens with judo a lot when people are
just getting involved there's a lot of
scrambling on the feet that could put
your legs in a compromised position when
your knee blows out how much isn't your
time watching the UFC how many of the
takedowns do you see or judo based it's
not that often but some guys are really
good at it and the guys that are really
good at it it comes up you know there's
there's there's some guys back when Karo
Parisyan was fighting karo was a great
judo player who was in the early earlier
days of the successful UFC was one of
the better judo guys and he would hit he
would hit hip tosses and all kinds of
different judo throws all the time and
Ronda of course you would do it all the
time too but with Ronda that was
basically the only way she would take
you down was with like upper body grabs
should grab shoot her move was like to
grab with grab the head and then take
people down with that and and use judo
but it does happen
but it only happened you know it happens
with skilled players yeah but when when
it does happen it's like it's a it's a
big surprise oftentimes like whoa
[Applause]